(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] I,
- I can't believe I'm here with you.
- [Kelly] I know, I'm excited
to meet you, I'm so excited.
Wait, okay, so wait. I'm
gonna first start with,
the holidays are here.
You look beautiful in red, by the way.
This is a color for you.
- Than you very much.
I'm really trying to ground myself
'cause I'm looking into your
eyes and this is so cool.
- Oh my god, same.
- Oh my god.
- And I literally, and I was so excited
'cause last night I was like reading up.
I always do like my
homework before I ever,
because I know things
about like your work,
but I don't, never like the
personal, most personal thing.
- You know about my work?
- Yeah, all your work.
- Oh my gosh!
- And, yes, anyway,
- I voted for you on American Idol!
- Oh my god!
Well, I have seen everything you're in,
- I saw From Justin to
Kelly the day it came out.
- Oh my God, that's a
real fan, okay. (laughs)
This is not good.
I, I never,
we're gonna get into that
acting versus singing.
- [Brie] Okay.
- But before we get there, like,
for the holidays, do you
get into this, are you?
- [Brie] I, I really do.
- I feel like we, I know
I was reading up on you,
I feel like we're so,
- Yeah, I really,
- [Kelly] You love giving gifts.
I love giving gifts.
- [Kelly] Like thoughtful... me too.
- I've already started, I'm
like a month in already.
- I usually start in October.
- [Brie] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because I feel
like it starts to come,
you start to see things and you go, oh,
I should get that for this person.
And why wait?
- And if you wait, it, all of a sudden
everything hits you and you have no time.
- Exactly.
And I also like to wrap my presents...
- [Kelly] Me too.
- ...really well.
- Yes, I make all the tags.
It's a whole thing that takes time.
- People offer don't to
do it and I'm offended.
- No!
- I'm like, no, you're
gonna ruin it, yeah.
- [Brie] No.
- Yeah, I do the like bits and bobbles.
I do tags, I do everything.
- I have a theme every year.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- It's a thing, it's a thing, yeah.
- This year I think I'm going with just
solid parchment, like classic, yeah.
- [Brie] Mhmm, with, with twine?
- 'Cause usually... yes!
- Yes, I've done that.
- And usually... yes!
- Brown paper packages
tied up with string!
- [Kelly] But then splashes of color, yes.
- Yep, no, I did that a couple years ago.
- Favorite things!
I love you so much, we should be friends.